with the division too so close to being
launched I'm seeing a lot of questions
in the community from people new to the
franchise wanting to know what they've
missed from the story from the division
one there's a bit of a catch up for
myself and anyone else interested in
this side of the game this video will be
about wrapping up the story would have
experienced so far before we start
digging into the division two already
confirmed is that a number of characters
stories will be continuing into the
sequel I won't be going into particular
detail on any of these stories but I'll
give a reference at the end of the video
if you'd like to learn more
[Music]
[Music]
you
following Black Friday retails busiest
day of the year a number of people
started getting sick and it was
spreading rapidly initially the symptoms
were mistaken for a severe case of the
flu however when people started dying
medical personnel eventually found out
that was an outbreak of the previously
eradicated smallpox virus to combat the
outbreak a smallpox vaccine was
distributed to the public
unfortunately the vaccine was quickly
proven ineffective and things were about
to get a whole lot worse
city infrastructure will start will
break down hospitals were overloaded and
the New York Police Force was struggling
to maintain the peace gains of rioters
were starting to carve out territories
in the city eventually the government
has simple the new line of defense to
maintain order a group that was composed
of the police firefighters civil
volunteers in the National Guard though
known as the joint task force or JTTF
their job to stop the spread of the
virus and maintain order the plan was
simply all no an infected individual is
to be relocated to the center of the
city separate from the uninfected in
order to stop these people from leaving
and mixing to the public a large Ward
would be built around the quarantine
area this way the spread would be halted
and there would be in a better position
to bring in the appropriate personnel to
get them the help they needed but
eventually the situation got worse and
more than the JTF could handle sickness
was starting to affect their numbers and
one of the private military contractors
brought in to help keep the peace known
as the last man battalion cut ties with
the JTF and started taking control of
parts of the city for themselves on top
of this through a number of other
hostile factions starting to rise like
the cleanest and the escaped convicts
known as the Rikers
[Music]
this is when the first wave of the
strategic homeland division agents were
activated their goal to assist the JTF
and regain control of the city
unfortunately it was too late
shortly after the first web division
agents were released into the dark zone
the government and the JTF pulled out
leaving behind supplies medicine weapons
thousands infected in the first wave
agents abandoned and cut off from the
outside world many agents succumb to the
virus who were killed by the growing
hostile factions within the quarantine
zone the area that would later be known
as the dark zone the first wave of
division agents were labeled mi a
presumed it this is the event that
triggered the second wave to be
activated their goal was to investigate
what happened to the first wave and
assist the JTF in restoring order in New
York City the commander in charge and
the majority of the second wave division
agents were being flown in by helicopter
to assemble themselves just outside of
the hostile zone before they could land
they were suddenly struck by an inbound
missile causing the helicopter to crash
killing everyone on board
it was now down to just a couple of
remaining shd agents to carry out the
mission New York City was in a horrific
state and there were rumors of how the
rest of the world wasn't doing too much
better austell factions have sectioned
off parts of the city fighting for
territory there were the Rikers who had
escaped from the prison on Rikers Island
they took advantage of the dwindling
prison staff who were either sick or no
longer turning up to work once on the
mainland their goal was to wreak as much
havoc as possible on society the society
that had them locked away especially
authority figures like the JTF other
groups weren't necessarily born out of
hate the cleaners came about with the
best of intentions they were among the
thousands of civilians left behind in
the dark zone when the JTF pulled out
these were the workers that were helping
the JTF and keeping the city
infrastructure ticking along
construction workers sanitation genesis
garbageman truck drivers they were also
heavily involved to the construction of
the quarantine zone wall but when the JT
have suddenly picked up and left
these civilians decided to take it upon
themselves to do what was needed to
contain the virus and restore order to
the streets of New York and the way they
decided to do this is to
everything that have been in contact
with the virus contaminated items the
bodies of those who died and anyone
living that may have become infected the
LMB or last man battalion are a private
military contractor made up of US
military veterans they were hired by
large Wall Street companies wanted to
protect their assets the lnb worked
alongside the JTF to start with but as
time went on they watched the city go
from bad to worse sick of the indecisive
local authorities and the government's
complete lack of ability to control the
situation the LMB decided it was up to
them to restore order to the city they
broke their contract and cut ties with
the JTF executing an officer in the
process from here they proceeded to do
what they deemed as necessary to rectify
the situation at hand
[Music]
second wave agents eventually found out
that the source of the virus outbreak
came from the New York department store
Able's and that the man responsible was
adopted Gordon Amherst the omission was
now to locate Amherst and find out what
he knows in order to develop a cure
however the second wave are also about
to make another discovery it was found
that the first wave agents aren't all
dead in fact they were very much alive
except now they were working against the
government they'd gone rogue
after the government pulled out of the
quarantine zone the first wave agents
were unhappy with how things have been
handled by the JTF and government and
this is where were introduced to a
prominent figure in the division
storyline Aron kena
Aron kena was a first wave agent who
after the abandonment of the quarantine
zone became disillusioned with the
government its plan to save the city and
his role within the division kina
disavowed the division and went rogue
his first action after turning against
the government was to recruit other
first wave agents into his new focus of
survival and power any agents that
refused were killed causing other agents
to cut communications and go into hiding
after forming this group of rogue agents
kena met up with a commanding officer of
the last man battalion they agreed to
collaborate through a deal that will
benefit them both kena want to use the
LMB
to assistant operations to establish
dominance over Manhattan and the LMB
wanted access to the division shade
technology to gain advantage over out
the hostile factions Kino would the LMB
launched many operations against
opposing groups including the JTF the
most notable one being an attack on a
helicopter that was carrying the
division commander there was a charge of
the second wave of division agents
during his time with the LMB Kino was
also investigating the virus outbreak
he found that dr. Gordon Amherst was
responsible
kinas investigation led him to adopt a
vitally Tanika and the Russian consulate
who was also researching the virus he
organized some of his rogue agents to
kidnap Tanika and his research he Naveen
found Amherst lab as well as some virus
samples at 3d DNA printer and Amherst
notes his plan is to use turn echo and
the samples to weaponize the virus and
use it to fulfill his belief that only
those who are smart and good enough
survive the old rules laws and
governments are gone now only power and
survival matter it was at this time that
Amherst was found shortly after the
outbreak was discovered that Amherst had
fallen to his own creation
notes recordings detailed why he did it
his reason for creating and spreading
the virus was that humanity was too
powerful on a global scale and her
mother nature needed help in advancing
her creations mankind is the greatest
threat to the survival of the planet
through their own greed but he had the
cure Amherst also had a darkness point
of view only the strong deserved to live
and his creation was the tool to ensure
that this happens but at the same time
he is willing and accepted that his
death may come through his own creation
he was able to modify the basic smallpox
virus by combining it with several other
dangerous diseases like Ebola and h1n1
on top of the serum notified the genetic
traits that controlled the incubation
period and made it so it could spread
even while it was incubating in the host
this made it particularly lethal because
by the time the host was showing
symptoms it had already spread to a
significant number of others using a
protein printer Amherst was able to
create the final form of this virus just
in time for Black Friday his plan was to
spread his new virus via the means that
were most handled during the shopping
holiday
money hence the name the dollar flew
slowly the second wave agents in the JTF
were able to push back the hostile
factions and regain control of the city
the Rikers and the cleaner leadership
was taken care of crippling their
advances the LMB will push back to their
final stronghold located in the United
Nations building during the lengthy
battle here betrays the LMB and escapes
with training co and his fellow rogue
agents the lmv is licked to be slowly
taken apart by the division agents it
was later discovered that kindred spent
some time on the westside pier at the
stage all hostile groups had feuds
against him most of all the LMP he
broadcasted his location to bring all
hostile factions into this area to hunt
him down
which in turn brought the JTF and the
division agents whose distraction helped
keep the hostile groups from finding him
he also taunted the division agents
stating that no one will ever find him
and despite quarantines and lockdowns of
the island he'll be soon gone it's now
confirmed that Erik here is long gone
from Manhattan and New York City all
together we have confirmation that
keener is or was in Washington but he
continues to leave messages to the JTF
and government agents to convince them
of his ways and beliefs and to join him
in his agents and work against the
government his final message was to
inform us that his eyes were not just
sit on the United States but now the
world as I said earlier this was just a
summary of the division one bring us up
to speed with a continuation of the
story and the division two if there were
any more characters that have briefly
ran through that you'd like to hear a
little more about I have a bunch of
other lore videos that go into a little
bit more dips I'll have these listed in
the description I'm really looking
forward to the division two story and
the companion books and comics of which
are hopefully only way to me right now
I've been deliberately holding off from
finding out too much information until
the game was being released I want to be
able to take it all in before I start
sickening and breaking it down I hope
you've enjoyed the video this will be my
last until after the full release so
thanks for watching and I'll catch you
in the next one
Cheers
you
you